[Musique]
bonjour merci de nous avoir rejoint dans
fileco l'émission qui revient sur
l'actualité économique locale on
commence tout de suite avec les grandes
lignes de cette émission mouvement de
grève nationale de la fonction publique
aujourd'hui en tête de fil de cette
grève la CGT qui réclame surtout une
revalorisation des salaires nous
retrouverons des gréistes à Versailles à
Versailles toujours mais aussi dans les
villes alentours la circulation des bus
est particulièrement perturbée en cause
le blocage du dépôt de bus de
l'entreprise Febus et puis nous
découvrirons les activités de
l'association EPA Entreprendre pour
apprendre avec notre invité Camille blzé
bonsoir bonsoir nous parlons plus
particulièrement des mini entreprises
dont vous avez notamment la charge ici
dans la région île-de-fance en un mot il
s'agit d'entreprises créées dans des
établissements scolaires par des
collégiens et des lycéen on en parle
dans un instant et avant ça on passe aux
informations économiques de la
semaine aujourd'hui de nombreux
fonctionnaires étaient en grève un
mouvement national pour dénoncer
principalement le gel de leur salairire
à Versailles une centaine de gréistes
ont manifesté soutenu notamment par la
CGT il réclam une révalorisation du
point d'indice des salaires une
meilleure reconnaissance des
qualifications ou encore l'égalité
salariale entre les hommes et les femmes
je vous propose des écouter l'un de ces
gréistes il y a des augmentations pour
certains de temps en temps mais que pour
les haut cadres c'estàdire que je vais
prendre l'exemple moi je suis dans la
police un commissaire de police peut
toucher une prime de 50000 € et on nous
dit qu'il y a pas d'argent pour payer
des papiers des crayons ou même
embaucher des gens je dira que cela on
peut embaucher au moins deux trois
personnels voire même un commissaire on
aimerait bien pas manifester juste avoir
notre juste d on demande pas plus on
demande juste que nos droits soient
respecté et autre mouvement de grève le
dépôt de bus du réseau Febus est bloqué
à depuis lundi les conducteurs dénoncent
leurs conditions de travail ils
manifestaient dans les rues de la ville
encore aujourd'hui la direction souhaite
que le dialogue reprennent en attendant
aucun bus ne circule des arrêts vides
pas de voyageurs depuis lundi le trafic
du réseau fbus est interrompu sur
Versailles en cause unee grève massive
des conducteurs qui bloquent le dépôt
les usagers prennent leur mal en
patience B il y a aucun bus donc c'est
un peu galère parce que moi je suis
étudiante je suis au lycée en fait et
donc pour venir bah ça me prend deux
fois plus de temps par je devenis à pied
je viens de Fontenel Fleury et ce matin
ben j'ai dû marcher depuis la gare de
chantier jusqu'au centre de versaill du
côté des conducteurs 215 se déclarent
gréviste sur les 365 salariés que compte
l'entreprise versaillaise la raison du
malaise des salaires qui n'augmentent
pas suffisamment et des conditions de
travail jugé difficiles nous avons
conditions de travail en ce moment qui
sont difficiles des temps de parcours
qui sont serré année en année ils
arrêtent de N retirer sur le temps de
parcours ilur TR temps de parcours et le
temps de battement pour l'augmentation
de salaire donc la direction nous a
donné 0,8 on de fois donc on éétait pas
d'accord sur ça la direction a fait la
sour de reil ils veulent pas avancer la
direction de son côté estime avoir tenté
d'échanger avec les grevistes pour
débloquer le dépôt et mettre en place un
service minimum un dialogue compliqué
selon le directeur moi je suis tout à
fait ouvert à la discussion avec les
grevistes tout à fait disposés à les
rencontrer euh dans le cadre d'une
réunion euh éventuellement organisé mais
euh pour autant et ça c'est très
important que le dépôt euh puisse être
libéré et que les conducteurs qui
souhaitent travailler puissent
travailler parce que pour l'instant le
droit euh de travail de des salariés de
de Febus n'est pas n'est pas
complètement respecté le réseau fbus
compte 26 lignes elles sont toutes
actuellement bloquées 60000 usagers
utilisent les services de
bus après des années de négociation la
taxe européenne sur les transactions
financières ne ne verra finalement le
jour que sous une forme édulcorée c'est
ce qui ressort des annonces de l'Union
européenne du 6 mai dernier les
ministres de l'économie et des finances
ont adopté les grandes lignes de cette
taxe mise en place en 2016 dans 11 pays
de l'Union dont la France elle ne
concernera que les actions et quelques
produits dérivés selon les estimations
elle ne rapporterait alors plus que 4,6
milliards d'euros pour l'organisation
altermondialiste attaque il s'agit là
d'un échec du au pression des lobby
financiers et du gouvernement français
leur but original était de limiter la
spéculation finan
et de taxer notamment les taux de change
je propose d'écouter la réaction du
président yvelinois d'attaque au début
on était plutôt plutôt enthousiaste
enfin fa fa quelque chose mais là le
projetel qui ces dernières semainesel
qui sort il est vide il est quasiment
vide le principe de ces transactions
c'est que vous faites 10000 transactions
dans la journée sur lequ vous gagnez pas
grandchose chaque fois on vous taxe un
peu vous
arrêtez la taxe l'objet c'est pas de
rapporter de l'argent c'est d'empêcher
les gens de de
spéculer
donc au départ on était parti sur une
taxe qui devait rapporter 35 milliards
d'euros aujourd'hui on estime à 3 et
demi c'est-à-dire que 90 % de ce qui
était la taexe d'origine a disparu il
reste plus que 10 % les fonctionnaires
français qui représentent la France à
l'Europe qui sont au ordre du
gouvernement donc sont largement
responsables complètement responsables
de cette de cet échec parce que pour
nous c'est un
échec machiniste développeur
informatique conducteur de travaux des
métiers por que le meddeef souhaite
mettre en valeur l'organisation
patronale estime qu'il existe 400000
emplois non pourvus en France car trop
souvent méconnu le meddef a donc lancé
hier une campagne de spot télévisé comme
vous voyez à l'écran des programmes
d'une minute intitulé beau travail
diffusé sur France 2 et France 3 jusqu'à
fin décembre coût de l'opération 4
million d'euros beau travail présente
115 salariés dont un machiniste d'une
entreprise de nettoyage desessarlereroi
serviclean le PDG de cette entreprise
nous explique ses besoins et pourquoi il
a parti participer à cette initiative je
dirais qu'on est en perpétuel
recrutement de de gens aujourd'hui par
exemple je suis en recrutement de de
deux chefs
d'équipe de trois machinistes et deux
laveurs de vitre et c'est des métiers
qu'aujourd'hui on narrive pas à trouver
sur le marché l'intérêt de beau travail
c'est qu'effectivement par ces spots à
courte durée on montre que notre métier
le métier de la propreté ne se contente
pas de d'un d'une personne qui nettoie
manuellement des locaux mais qui y a
aussi une évolution vers en utilisant
des machines très spécifiques et adapté
à chaque
[Musique]
site et pour l'entretien nous recevons
aujourd'hui Camille blaé bonjour bonjour
vous êtes chargé de mission pour
l'association pa Île-de-France alors pa
ça signifie Entreprendre pour Apprendre
est-ce que vous pouvez nous en dire un
peu plus alors donc Entreprendre pour
Apprendre est association qui
sensibilise les jeunes à
l'entrepreneuriat nos valeurs ne sont
pas d'en faire des entrepreneurs mais de
de leur permettre d'acquérir des
savoir-faire des savoir-être et de
prendre leur vie en main voilà les
quelques mots de nos de nos valeurs al
vous faites partie de de l'association
du département du de la région pardon
île- de-fance mais il y en a d'autres
vous êtes présents un peu partout en
France finalement tout à fait on est
donc une association île-de-fance au
niveau de la région de la région mais
également on a une fédération et on
couvre l'ensemble de l'île-de-fance
également la Corse et même la Martinique
la seule région pour l'instant où nous
ne sommes pas implantés et lumosin faire
un appel donc du coup jamais tout alors
opepa accompagne 15000 jeunes par an à
travers différents programmes donc on va
les présenter les trois principaux donc
pour les plus jeunes il y a notre
commune alors qu'est-ce que vous faites
avec notre commune al notre commune
s'adresse à élèves de primaire donc du
CE2 au CM2 et en fait à travers ce
programme on explique aux jeunes quel
est le circuit de l'argent voilà parfois
on ne sait pas forcément dans une ville
bah le circuit de l'argent que par
exemple l'école ne la paye pas mais ça
un cût donc à travers un jeu un jeu on
découvre le circuit de l'argent tout au
long de l'année à travers différentes
interviews de professionnels de
l'entreprise mais également des des
travaux que font les professeurs avec
leurs élèves tout au long de l'année
l'idée c'est d'introduire à chaque fois
des entrepreneurs finalement dans les
écoles exactement voilà pour les
sensibiliser dès le plus jeune âge alors
une deuxième action dont on peut parler
le start-up programme qui est à
destination cette fois des plus grandes
des étudiants exactement alors le
startup programme EPA est un projet donc
euh on va dire comme un projet de mini
entreprise en plus grand ils ont à
chaque fois des à chaque é ils ont cinq
étapes cette fois-ci ils doivent valider
par un des juris de professionnels leur
leur projet et donc le 10 avril il y a
eu a eu le championnat national des des
du start-up programme et c'est une
équipe franilienne qui représentera la
France au championnat européen européen
euréen voilà pardon au mois de juillet à
Amsterdam alors donc finalement c'est
l'idée c'est de créer des entreprisees
dans dans les universités il y a aussi
ce système là dans les collèges et les
lycées ça s'appelle la mini entreprise
on va d'ailleurs en parler un peu plus
particulièrement comment ça fonctionne
alors une mini entreprise donc c'est un
projet pédagogique qui dure sur une
année scolaire donc on connait le début
et on connaît également la fin et ça
s'adresse à des élèves donc ce soit en
collège ou en lycée voilà et donc on
travaille particulièrement avec des trè
mais également après des lycéens de
seconde ou de première et ça s'adresse à
tous les élèves on n pas de on n pas de
d'élèves en particulier voilà toutes les
filières sont les bienvenu c'est ouvert
à tous alors dans le département on en
compte 24 exactement on en a suivi deux
plus particulièrement secure life du
collège Jul ferie à monent- la jolie et
roule et range du lycée jean-villard à
plaisir je vous propose de découvrir du
coup ensemble un petit peu leur activité
leur
fonctionnement j'aimerais bien un court
texte explicatif explicatif du produit
euh alors d'abord moi j'avais pensé un
paragraphe avec avec la description de
notre activité pourquoi on fait ça dans
quel cadre Antonin guide l'activité de
ses camarades car comme chaque lundi il
a troqué son habit d'écolier pour celui
de PDG dans cette salle de cours pas de
professeurs au tableau ni de prise de
notes ces lycéens travaillent au
développement de leur mini entreprise
roule et range leur activité
l'achatavente d'enrouleur d'écouteur
donc voilà l'enrouleur d'écouteur on
essaie d'associer la pratique à
l'esthétique donc ici on va ajouter
notre le logo de notre entreprise et par
la suite donc là pour l'instant notre
cible principale ça sera les
particuliers et par la suite on va
essayer de cibler des professionnels ça
peut être des entreprises en rapport
avec la musique ou la jeunesse
l'adolescence pour essayer d'avoir des
des clients dans le domaine
professionnel à l'initiative de ce
projet l'association
EPA Entreprendre pour apprendre chaque
année elle accompagne plus de 15000
jeunes pour leur insiffler l'esprit
d'entreprendre en début d'année ces
lcéans de plaisir ont choisi de se
positionner sur une activité spécifique
ils ont élu leur président et leur
directeur général pour le reste de
l'équipe il a fallu passer un véritable
entretien d'embauche c'est comme un
entretien dans dans une vraie entreprise
chacun préparé son dossier ça de
motivation son
chaque lycéen participant au projet a
intégré un service à chacun sa
spécialité les finances la technique ou
encore le marketing 15 % 15 % minimum
préciseele bien parce que là sinon ça
fait radin j'aime pas pour les encadrés
des professeur un responsable de
l'association EPA et un Parin if tenes
est lui-même chef d'entreprise et les
aides semaine après semaine ça va passer
par comment mener un entretien
d'embauche comment faire un business
plan tout ça de manière très simple
c'est très ludique comment faire un plan
commercial ou ou un projet de
communication et de marketing voilà
c'est juste mon expérience les grandes
clés pour que bah qu'ils arrivent à
concevoir et aller au bout de leur
projet aujourd'hui leurs parrains les
aident à préparer un discours commercial
car samedi ils vont profiter des portes
ouvertes de leur établissement pour
commencer leur premières vente
l'approche tu peux dire regardez c'est
souple c'est incassable machin et hop tu
le donnes pour leur professeurs
d'économie gestion ce cours un peu
particulier reste un véritable ignement
pour ses élèves moi ce qui me plaît
c'est le côté concret où on met les
élèves en situation ou plutôt que de
leur apprendre ce qu'est la valeur
ajoutée ce qu'est un seuil de
rentabilité ce qu'est un compte de
résultat comment on lance une campagne
de marketing bah c'est les mettre dans
le vif du sujet les confrontter à la
réalité et les rendre responsable et
autonome par rapport à ce genre de
projet dans les ivelines on compte 23
mini entreprises amant la jolie ces
collégiens ont opté pour une toute autre
activité la confection et la vente de
porte-clés présentant les gestes de
premier secours au final ça donnera ça
donc il y a comme gris noir rouge bleu
et après il y aura d'autres teintes de
couleurs qui vont arriver comme le jaune
ou le vert aujourd'hui les différents
services sont un peu chamboulés tout le
monde met la main à la patte pour
répondre aux commandes aujourd'hui on
est vraiment dans la phase technique
donc on est en train de vraiment
concevoir les les portesclés pour
vraiment que avant la fin des vacances
on est on est fait pas mal là on a
commencé à peu près une petite dizaine
on a reçu déjà plusieurs bon de commande
donc ça serait vraiment pour les envoyer
durant les vacances LAN le directeur
général aide le service technique avec
une machine utilisée habituellement en
cours de technologie la mini entreprise
peut réaliser les pores-clés de A à Z ça
c'est la disposition sur la plaque des
des pores-clés et en vert là c'est le
parcours de la de la fraise après
l'usinage il faut découper les
différents textes explicatifs et
procéder à l'assemblage elle est où ta
ça et il reste encore du travail s'ils
veulent à terme rentabiliser leur
activité l'objectif ouais c'est de faire
du bénéfice et à partir de 99 c'est
bénéfique après le bénéfice on on
donnera 15 % à une association la Ligue
contre le cancer chaque mini entreprise
choisit une association à qui elle
reversera un pourcentage des bénéfices
mais avant de parler de Bénéfic il a
fallu réfléchir à l'investissement pour
cela les mini entrepreneurs ont vendu
des avances remboursables principalement
à leurs proches en clair des actions
sans dividend possible de 4 € chacune
auxquelles se sontjoutés des dons le
matériel leur a pour le moment coûter
200 € vient leur descomes on avait pas
loin de 700 c'est ça00 voilà donc là il
doit nous rester 500 on compte leschec
il y en a pas mal de Monna aussi et aon
a loyer à payer ici c'est 1 € tous les
mois mais voilà la mini entreprise prend
la place de l'option découverte
professionnelle 3h pour leur professeur
l'objectif du cours est pleinement
atteint ça permet de travailler
autrement avec les élèves de travailler
un projet un vrai
projet de responsabiliser et d'apporter
beaucoup d'autonomie chez eu C cur Life
a été sélectionné pour participer au
concours régional des mini entreprises
Alexandra prépare la décoration du stand
qu'il tiendront pour présenter leur
activité une grande affiche comme ça qui
sera installé plus en hauteur pour que
tout le monde les voie et puis que ça
attire du monde retour c'est Villard de
plaisir c'est aujourd'hui les portes
ouvertes la mini entreprise roule et
range présente et vend ses enrouleurs
l'histoire des services est un petit peu
abandonné pour ce matin en tout cas on
essaie tous de se répartir les tâches il
y a un groupe d'élèves qui se trouve en
bas à l'entrée pour pour amener les gens
vers la salle il y en a d'autres aussi
qui se promènent dans le lycée pour
attirer la foule et nous on gère on gère
à l'intérieur pour vendre le produit et
gérer en même temps l'argent qui rentre
et qui sort dans les couloirs le service
financier tente d'attirer des clients
dans notre enseignement d'exploration en
ses on crée une mini entreprise pour
nous apprendre bah les bases de
l'entreprise dans la dans la dans la
vraie vie quoi et donc notre principe on
vend des enrouleurs d'écouteurs roul
range a réuni près de 500 € grâce aux
avances remboursables et elle a vendu
pour le moment une trentaine de rouleurs
pour arriver à l'équilibre il faut qu'on
en vende exactement
80 pour bah oui pour avoir un équilibre
et après tout ce qui sera en plus ça
fera du bénéfice une partie de ce
bénéfice sera reversée à l'association
soleil d'enfants roul range a également
été sélectionné pour le concours
régional cette journée sonne donc comme
une phase de test et c'est à Paris que
nous allons retrouver ces de mini
entreprise alors donc on le voit bien
c'est finalement des vraies entreprises
au sein des établissements chacun donc a
un poste dédié on voyait le le collège
par exemple pay même un loyer un loyer
symbolique d'un € donc le but c'est
vraiment de découvrir le fonctionnement
alors tout à fait on leur explique voilà
dans une entreprise on on a des charges
on a donc des charges on leur explique
la différence entre les charges fixes
les charges variables on leur explique
également qu'il faut trouver un capital
de départ donc vous l'avez très bien
expliqué avec les avances remboursable
donc euh on ils essayent d'aller les
vendre à leurs proches mais on essaie
aussi de les ouvrir vers l'extérieur et
de leur de leur expliquer qu'il faut
aller voir les commerçants aller voir
des entreprises euh la mini secure life
qu'on voit dans le reportage qui est
intéressant c'est bah ils ont eu
l'opportunité d'avoir deux parins un
entrepreneur local et un autre un autre
parins qui vient du Groupe HSBC et du
coup cette cet apport bah de deux chefs
d'entreprise de deux personnes de
l'entreprise ça leur a permis de bah
d'ouvrir vraiment sur leur vision leur
champ de vision sur sur le monde
extérieur en dehors de l'établissement
exactement et c'est vraiment la force et
tout comme roule et range la mini secure
Life a eu l'opportunité de vendre ses
créations avec d'autres mini entreprises
du mentoi à auchamp et ils ont fait une
belle prestation voilà c'est vraiment
toute cet aspect vers l'extérieur qu'on
essaie de développer alors vous parliez
des parins des différentes m entreprises
vous-même vous allez les rencontrer
comment vous les aidez alors nous notre
rôle en tant que référent de projet donc
toutes les personnes qui accompagnent
des projets dans notre association on à
peu près une vingtaine de projets à
suivre tout au long de l'année donc on
les aideent de la recherche de l'idée
jusqu'à à la fin le bilan de leur de
leur entreprise on passe par l'étude de
marché l'étude de faisabilité mais
également on les aide à à créer le
recrutement donc on fait venir des
partenaires extérieurs qui sont dans les
ressources humaines on passe également
par la la l'évaluation de de leur coût
enfin on crée leur budget prévisionnel
avec eux on les on les accompagne bah
dans le processus pour trouver leur nom
leur identité euh vraiment on passe on
les aide un peu dans tout dans écrire la
écrire des courriers voilà donc c'est
vraiment un apprentissage de tous les
jours jour et puis un accompagnement
tout au long de la mini puis on les
prépare pour le championnat des mini
entreprises alors justement donc il y a
un championnat on confronte finalement
ces mini entreprises avant de développer
un peu plus je vous prop propose de
regarder ensemble on va retrouver roule
et range et secure life au concours
régional à
Paris c'est le grand jour pour les mini
entrepreneurs mercredi une soixantaine
de mini entreprise sélectionnées partout
en Île-de-France s'affronter pour
emporter un prix voir pour les meilleurs
une sélection pour le championnat de
France Alexandra et son équipe de Secur
life font partie de ces sélectionnés
depuis ce matin ils présentent aux
visiteurs leurs produits ce porte-clé
avec les gestes des premiers secours
pour le moment l'accueil est assez bon
je trouve que c'est vraiment une bonne
idée nécessaire qui peut rendre service
oui ou oui depuis le lancement de leur
vente mi-avril leur mini entreprise a
écouller 111 porte-clés de quoi être
rentable un bon point pour eux mais les
participants ne sont pas notés que sur
le rentabilité financière il y a des
juris qui viennent nous poser énormément
de questions donc sur comment on a eu
l'idée sur le financement du projet
qu'on va faire des bénéfices et autr et
puis jusqu'à présent on se déouille
plutôt bien donc on attend la suite à
quelques pas de là l'équipe de roule et
range reçoit justement la visite d'un
membre du jury Anton compte bien
remporter un prix mais il reconnait
qu'il y a de la concurrence que même les
collèges 3è qui font des super trucs
vraiment c'est il y a de l'innovation
partout il y a de l'idée il y a il y a
du potentiel donc c'est vrai que on est
on est vraiment dans un dans un concours
au critères assez compliqué donc c'est à
nous de nous investir d'autant plus pour
accéder à une place assez intéressante
mais en même temps on saluera bien le
travail des autres parce que c'est c'est
vraiment il y a vraiment du du niveau
quoi à côté de nous il y a en effet du
niveau des Hans de bol des porte-clés
siffleurs mais surtout d'autres
enrouleurs d'écouteurs comme cet arrête
de poisson ou encore ce winzic un
produit créé par ses collégiens qui ne
compte pas se faire voler la vedette on
a fait le produit de A à Z eux ils ont
que acheté
donc c'est notre marque de fabrique en
fait heureusement pas de concurrence
directe entre les deux produits les
collégiens et les lycéens ne sont pas
jugés dans la même catégorie en fin
d'après-midi les différents membres du
jury se retrouve pour délibérer les
trois meilleures mini entreprises de
chaque catégorie seront sélectionnées
pour le championnat de France
les partenaires de l'association EPA
remettent qu à eux des prix
complémentaires comme le prix de la
mobilité du meilleur film publicitaire
ou du meilleur stand
comm au niau
du à cette tablees salariés de
l'entreprise partenaire Oracle cherch à
récompenser la meilleure innovation
comme une quinzaine de leursollègues ils
sont ici en tant volonir et sont
impressionné on a été bluffé ouais il y
a il y a une énergie extraordinaire il y
a beaucoup d'innovation il y a beaucoup
de de leçons que tous on ont appris en
se confrontant aux différents aspects de
l'entreprise après délibération vient le
temps de découvrir quelle mini
entreprise ont conquis les différents
membres du jury dans le public on attend
avec impatience le premier prix le
meilleur film publicitaire est annoncé
dans la catégorie
lycéeou
plis sourire au lèvres les lycé vient
récupérer leur prix une belle récompense
Eton peine à y
croire les PR s'enchaînent mais nos
collégiens de Monte la jolie ne seront
pas en reste ils obtiennent le prix de
l'innovation réussi pour le collège Jul
ferry et des collégiens ravis ça fait
plaisir on voit qu'on est récompensé du
travail qu'on a fait pour les de mini
entreprise iinoise l'aventure s'arrêtera
là mais elle aura été riche en
enseignement découverte du milieu
professionnel cohésion d'équipe ces
écoliers ne l'oublieront pas alors ils
son sont bien sortis finalement C ces de
min entreprisees donc ils vont pas
finalement au concours nationnal mais on
retrouvera d' tripinois tout à fait donc
la mini stuffine qui vient du lycée
militaire de saint-s l'école qui
représentera l'association
île-de-fance au concours national et on
les encourage de tout cœur on espère
qu'ils iront plus loin il y a derrière
finalement un concours européen alors on
l'a remporté enfin nous sommes arrivés
5e il y a 2 ans et on espère que ils
recommenceront cette prouesse à
l'Européen en européen donc en juillet
en Estonie alors juste un un dernier
point sur ces mini entreprise est-ce que
finalement des fois c'est ça peut peut
avoir des complications est-ce que il y
a toujours cette motivation qu'on a vu
dans c'est entreprise ou non alors dans
dans les projets bah comme dans tout
projet on a parfois des petites
difficultés mais en fait on se rend
compte que voilà il y a pas il y a pas
de il y a pas d'obstacle il peut y avoir
des petits des petits il faut prendre
des d'autres ralonges mais au final on
arrive quand même à à la fin de notre
projet parfois on va pas aussi loin que
le championnat mais c'est déjà une belle
victoire et on essaie de plus en plus
euh de créer des événements locaux pour
permettre à tous les jeunes de vivre une
manifestation telle que ils ont vécu
hier tout à fait pour vraiment voilà qui
est un but à la fin de l'entreprise en
plus de de tous les savoirs et tous les
savoirs-être acquis alors on est pris un
peu par le temps donc juste pour
conclure vous allez peut-être mettre en
place finalement un système plus réduit
pour permettre à plus d'établissements
qui n'ont pas forcément ces options DP3
ou ces options écogestion pour pour les
mettre en place dans les rétabliss
pour les établissements intéressés
comment faire alors c'est très simple
vous avez notre site
paidf.fr et vous avez un ch contact et
on peut nous contacter directement
parfait ben merci beaucoup en tout cas
d'être vevenenu sur notre plate merci à
vous de nous avoir invité et on passe à
l'agenda dans l'agenda cette semaine un
stage de formation à la création
d'entreprise la Chambre de commerce et
d'industrie des Yvelines vous propose de
découvrir les points essentiels pour se
lancer pendant 5 jours du 19 au 23 mai
de 9h à 17h30 il est ouvert à tous au
programme méthodologie règles
administrativ études de marché
rendez-vous sur le site de la CCI c'est
la fin de ce filcho merci de nous avoir
suivi on se retrouve la semaine
[Musique]
prochaine